[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su radio
sarebbe un gioco dove si possono
ascoltare le radio
no non è manco per il cazzo così
ovviamente so che un range game perché
mi avete consigliato dicendo fi wi fi
questo regime in porca [ __ ] ciao ho
proprio voglia di farlo in una maniera
che non avete idea comunque non sa anche
come cazzo si gioca quindi va bene
iniziamo a vedere che cazzo è sta roba
cosa devo fare
ma ce l'hai un cazzo di tutoria lo devo
andare così a caso come si gioca è il
gioco più difficile del mondo sono e
come si fa a partire bellissima se con
joystick il cazzo si infila so cosa
ragazzi partenza epica bellissimo ma il
tana [ __ ] vacca [ __ ] ma già sono
incazzato non so manco partito preso
trovami addio
ok mi chiama ditelo a ok perfetto che ho
capito devo far arrivare la pallina
sinistra c'è solo due tasti sto cazzo di
gioco però non è così semplice come
sembra la prima è andata ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta una stella sola su tre
meraviglioso per le stelle sono tipo il
corso del radioattivo ma ok se l'affetto
ce l'ha fatta cioè fatto ragazzi
incredibile tutto lui tutto lui rossi
c'è rossi c'è donna che record che re
dove sono le mie meda dove obama dove
cazzo e obama è una roba strana perché
c'è un portale d'evocazione ragazzi
cos'è quella roba in mezzo è una cagata
come concept casinò cioè non sembra così
a maya con tra se va bene chi cazzo mai
preso e un macello adesso non premere i
tasti opposti pure è pure un altro
scenario alla madonna e che cazzo ci vai
giù [ __ ] oppure cosa ha detto no no
no di quella madonnina sanibel
incazzature come dovremmo c fatto tutto
il mondo ok mi chiara cosa indecente
ragazzi un minuto per falsa cagata non
per dire ok no ma [ __ ] o due tasti da
premere non basta un cervello per farlo
perché il cervello dice no poco però
cazzo hai così vai così la propaggine
acuta no no è che cazzo a ce n'è un
altro show ecco perché ho mica mezzo
effetto sull 8 minuto e 4 sempre meglio
di prima ok basta ragazzi mi sono rotto
il cazzo questo tre su tre
voglio il punteggio massimo me frega un
cazzo cos'è achievement sbloccato a
madre sbloccato ha perso mi sta
prendendo per il culo cosa come faccio
la canzone anche andare avanti normale
no se perfetto adesso si mettono pure
gli ostacoli sticazzi ma fatemelo
di coscienza già non riesco così ok 20
secondi quante me ne da una due record
cazzo fantastico no è solo al traguardo
ragazzi va bene già così ma non vedo
anche dove sto andando meraviglioso no
ma il super suo dai anche questo anche
questo voglio due stelle almeno due poi
vai vai tira tira 6 cazzo due perfette
ormai la pro a chi nei ragazzi sta
diventando professionisti a sti giochi
c'è il prossimo video su sta roba è il
campionato mondiale di radium come anche
a passare sto cribbio di punto
figuriamoci ai dai su piuttosto ritorna
a giocare a cat mario cazzo ok minchia
la meraviglia perfetto ai vai giù by
giorgio spingi spingi come una lytham
ignota la no non indietro ti prego
perfetta adesso con la contrario
grandissimo ai controlli riesco meglio
cazzo non è possibile
dovrei dovrei riuscire meglio nell'altro
invece des come in questo non so perché
ma va bene così ecco come non detto
affanculo ragazzi sto sudando freddo non
ce la faccio più è la madonna è cotto
merdacce come tutta la vita ragazzi e
cinque minuti e li faccio tutti è
promesso veramente non sto scherzando
facciamo 7 ma perché non avevo fatto
questo tra l'altro basta che ci riesco
ragazzi non imporre ne frega niente ok
vai così vai così voglio vedere tutto
finito oh mio dio
la fragile ragazzo incredibile rossi c'è
però se c'è in vantaggio
rossi anche lui ma [ __ ] sono
cascate vabbè dai prima di testa prima
di 30 prima di 30 28 28 da almeno due
meno 2 cazzo
allora ragazzi per un attimo voglio
voglio vedere scoprendo la terza perché
assurdo vai vai vai tira tira tira tira
tira mi caccia faccia solito ce la
faccio incredibile a schumi e schumi
anche lui alonso tutti tutti insieme
[ __ ] miso intrippato contrario no
per ora perché chi blog di grillo ma
[ __ ] a [ __ ] bakkal aida
dai dai 24 24 6 3 stelle [ __ ]
radio ma chiede se è questa chi mente lo
dai a tua mamma ragazzi tre stelle che
poi non sono stelle sono tipo cose
radioattive cioè prima mente cide
formiamo a fare sti livelli ma ok
perfetto ragazzi 15 livelli di
radiazione quindi posso andare avanti e
facciamolo 11 vuoi vedere che cosa è lo
staff ci avrei scommesso la vita e
sarebbe stato un casino chiedevo no no
madonna ragazzi va bè impossibile ma
seriamente ma come fa dai dai dai dai
dai sì mi piace fare ok a posto come non
detto ragazzi come non detto però fatto
cagare il cazzo ma va bene così oh mio
dio e va bene destra vai vai tira tira
tira tira cioè la mamma [ __ ]
cosa fa non so come ho fatto a passare
ragazzi non ho idea io sopra ok ok 31 31
avete visto tutti che per un attimo che
lo domina ds3 cazzo ci sto prendendo un
po l'abitudine e ragga anche se mi fa un
po leggermente sempre incazzare ma non è
male se come ragazzi sto gioco l'ho
comprato solo io nella vita quindi senza
neanche volerlo sono campione mondiale
di sta merda perfetto no dice la
famiglia nelle spine dai tu no bravo
bravo bravissimo ciò fatta il peggio è
passato a [ __ ] tiro che vale tre
stelle vai vai giù sta diventando atroce
25 da tre stelle tra stelle una come una
base [ __ ] mica l'ho fatto in
velocissimo in velocissimo che italiano
questo fa tutto ragazzi non so premendo
un cazzo fa tutto lui vai vai vai vai
vai veloce donna più veloce mia nonna ma
dio santo dove va indietro no [ __ ]
cosa è successo come ho fatto a tornare
almeno assenti alla scorta di questo lo
devo fare almeno a tre stelle ci riesco
ok magari fai la partenza un po meglio
perfetto vai vai che cielo madonna
guardali che protesta che protesta
incredibile
[Musica]
18187 cioè gli scatti dj ragazzi non ci
si può credere sono fatte a fare tre
stelle anche nel secondo stage di
livelli incredibile grandissimo bravo
zio madonna sono stato un po basta
quando di queste cose poi inizia a far
cagare e infatti sto tornando indietro
dai porca [ __ ]
giuro che sto per uccidere una persona
non so chi esco e uccidono di cui non di
como donna coi ad extra cazzo a destra
bravo a destra destra al tuo cavallo a
destra tuo cane vai a destra cosa giochi
a counter strike mentre sono incazzato
cosa in europa non ha senso però dai dai
tira su spingi come se stessi cagando
c'è un minuto e 36 secondi per questa
merda vi rendete conto il disagio
stavolta no raga seriamente cosa mi
rappresenta sto schifo ma mai nella vita
riusciva a fini sta roba tipo 12 minuti
di livello ma va bene
contenti voi ragazzi vai vai vai vai vai
se ma 22 secondi incredibile compirò i
miei 30 anni mentre facciotto livello
cioè assurdo c'è una mente malata qua
dietro ma convinto proprio è non è
neanche tanto difficile da immaginare
ora che merda ok 58 secondi pensavo
peggio
nero non vedo un cazzo no ti prego ti
prego vai su modo un attimo risse la
famiglia di schiaffi quando non arriva a
una certa altezza mi sembra che debba
lasciare le mie forze morire perché mi
sento impotente a ma se li prendo tutti
e due siti la summa di tenere cose che
ne so madonna mi sembra un incrocio
ragazzi tra iwate supermicro 2 tutta na
c'ho creduto ed ai loro fare questo se
ce la faccio a far questo finito ragazzi
tutti come fate un applauso tutti
insieme se fate un applauso forte forte
fa vj riesce a fare il livello non mi
sento che mi guardi così non applaude
gli upload dire mai e le tre stelle
voglio tra in olio tranne voglio tre ne
voglio tre a mele fottute medaglie
faccio l'ultimo falso il 30 l'ultimo in
assoluto fi basta che cazzo cos'è sta
roba
cosa ho fatto non riuscirò mai più nella
vita vai vai vai veloce dai [ __ ]
tirati su mamma mia
vai così vai così vai così no
massimo madonna alla soddisfazione vai
vai vai era anche finito quante la prima
volta è una va bene d'accordo ragazzi
concluso qui l'episodio è stato alquanto
strano giocare un range game che è
piuttosto tranquillo un paio di schiaffi
l'avrei tirati uguale luca ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto così tanto quanto mi
piace anche a passare di facebook e come
vi trovate la descrizione susseguirsi di
sfilate i civili devono prossimo vi è
caduto il telecomando perché è gioca una
merda ma se lo rischierei si vedevano
prossimo video
ok ragazzi